tents have sprung up in hospital grounds
all over manila and its surrounding
suburbs
patients and their relatives are having
to wait under the heat to get into
emergency rooms or endure days in
makeshift wards kovit 19 is back with
the vengeance and is pushing hospitals
in the philippines to their limit
the philippine general hospital the
country's largest public health
institution has stopped accepting
non-cova-19 patients
the problem is we have a lot of
non-coveted patients who also
are filling up our beds and so that will
demand more nurses and doctors to take
care of them so this rapid increase in
the number of coveted missions made us
realize that we cannot serve both
the situation at the philippine general
hospital reflects what the health
department has been reporting
daily infections of more than 12
thousand for nearly a week and more
people dying
more than halfway through a two-week
lockdown in its capital region the
philippines continues to see a spike in
kovid19 cases
but this current wave of the virus isn't
limited to manila
elsewhere in the country the number of
infections is rising as well
winnie dougly's family lives in quezon
province more than 100 kilometers south
of manila
his father tested positive for kovy 19
before there was even talk of lockdown
yet they say it took them three days to
find him a hospital that had a bed
in one of the hospitals my dad was just
in the parking lot
the hospital staff prodded us to just
leave the hospital premises and maybe
try the provincial hospital when we
arrived there the triage doctor
surprisingly discouraged us to even try
our love there
dadley's father survived but had he
waited a few more days to be admitted
dougly says the story might have turned
out differently
but health experts worry the situation
could get worse
it seems like it's not slowing down at
all
in the past when you
do a lockdown or a dcq maybe about a
week later you see some slowing down
but we have not felt that
manila streets aren't as empty as one
would imagine during a lockdown
more businesses are allowed to operate
and more people are out and about
but health department officials say it
could take weeks before the impact of
this lockdown is felt
part below al jazeera manila